au canada 39 % des enfants de 5 à 11 ans
ont reçu leurs premières doses de vaccin
contre la co lead au québec c'est 56%
pendant ce temps des parents hésitent
encore
pourquoi vacciner les enfants alors que
pour eux les risques de la maladie sont
faibles en tire t'il vraiment bénéfices
doit-on les vacciner pour le bénéfice de
la collectivité
et comment la majorité des experts
peuvent ils recommandé avec tant de
certitudes ce vaccin nouveau genre
malgré le peu de recul nous avons
rencontré plusieurs experts dont ceux
qui ont formulé des recommandations aux
gouvernements du québec et du canada
pour comprendre zoom sur leurs
réflexions ce qui a guidé leur choix
pour nous et pour leurs familles
9 novembre 2020 santé canada donne le
feu vert à pfizer biotech pour l'emploi
de son vaccin chez les enfants
pour rendre leur décision les experts se
sont penchés en particulier sur les
études de phase 1 2 et 3 mené par la
compagnie la qualité du vaccin et son
processus de fabrication
sur la base c'est donner l'heure il
considère que le vaccin est assez
efficace et sécuritaire pour pouvoir
l'administré ou le donner à la
population canadien
mais santé canada ne répond pas à si
grande question est ce que les
gouvernements doivent recommandé ce
vaccin aux enfants à quel enfant avec
elle posologie
avec quelle urgence ces questions
reviennent à d'autres scientifiques
indépendants qui vont re et analyser les
données et se faire leur propre opinion
pour conseiller le gouvernement fédéral
c'est le comité consultatif national de
l'immunisation qui réunit une quinzaine
d'experts indépendants votant
au québec un autre groupe d'une
quinzaine de scientifiques indépendants
fait de même le comité sur
l'immunisation du québec dont fait
partie la spécialiste en santé publique
chantal sauvageau et la docteure couach
ce comité là est excessivement à l'affût
des données à une expertise en
immunologie et en vaccination qui est
incroyable en termes d' historique et de
connaissances et de compétences on
regarde toujours le fardeau de la
maladie l'efficacité de la vaccination
sa sécurité les enjeux d'acceptabilité
la conformité ce qui se fait ailleurs
les enjeux de faisabilité les enjeux
étaient le paradigme avec lequel on part
c'est pas nécessairement dire le
pharmaceutique leur commande donc on
fait pareil jamais durables stamping
mais c'est clairement pas une décision
qu'on prend à la légère
jamais
leur plus grande question est ce que les
enfants tireront un bénéfice direct du
vaccin car livré que pour eux les
complications de l'aco vides sont très
rares mais on s'est rendu compte dans la
dernière année que les enfants sont
sujets à ce qu'on appelle le syndrome
inflammatoire multi systémique une
complication pouvant conduire aux soins
intensifs et mener à des
dysfonctionnements de multiples organes
le coeur les reins le foie les poumons
dans leur analyse les comités doivent
donc comparer les risques de la maladie
au risque du vaccin d'abord pour la
maladie les estimations prudentes évalue
à un cas de syndrome inflammatoire multi
systémique sur 3000 enfants affectés le
docteur elie haddad et pédiatres
immunologue à l'hôpital sainte-justine
puisque la maladie va donner un cas
grave sur un sur trois mais il faut
surtout pas que le vaccin il nous donne
une myocardite sur 3000 scolasse des
stats bien idiot on est bien d'accord
lors de l'étude pisa biotech de phase
iii plus de 3000 enfants ont reçu le
vaccin ils sont comparés à un groupe
témoin d'enfants non vaccinés
on recense très peu d'effets secondaires
aucun grave et surtout pas de myocardite
cette inflammation du coeur qui avait
été observé après la vaccination des
jeunes adultes le risque de réactions
sévères et donc probablement inférieur à
1 sur 3000 par précaution en considérant
les marges d'erreur les experts
l'évaluent à moins de 1 sur 1000 mais ce
risque était le plus petit que les
risques de la maladie de 1 sur 3000
l'essai de phase i hope you and take ne
suffit donc pas à déterminer
par contre on a de plus en plus de
donner ici au québec aux états unis et
en israël quelques autres mais cesser
les plus solides qui monte chez les
adolescents il y a eu des mots car dit
suite à la vaccination rapportés mais
essentiellement chez le groupe des plus
vieux donc chez les 15-17 très peu dans
le groupe des 13 14 ans 12 encore moins
en israël sur 5 millions de personnes
vaccinées on a recensé 136 me au caire
dit c'est environ un cas sur cinquante
mille et ce avec une dose trois fois
plus élevée que celle donnée aux enfants
en israël ils ont donné deux doses à 21
jours nous en donne deux doses à huit
semaines et les ontariens ont bien
démontré que des thierry cet intervalle
diminue le risque
enfin environ 90% de ses nuits au caire
dit suivant un vaccin sont bénignes
traiter avec un simple anti
inflammatoires et du repos contrairement
au mit au karting posco vide souvent
bien plus graves avec des effets
potentiels à long terme tout indique
qu'à court terme les bénéfices connu
pour la santé l'emportent sur les
risques du vaccin
mais qu'en est il des effets à long
terme
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on a pas de recul sur le
vaccin mais on n'a pas de recul non plus
sur la maladie les risques inconnus de
la maladie il y en a plein parce qu'on
n'a pas encore l'évolution à long terme
d'un virus qu'ovide on sait pas ce que
ça va donner deux ou trois ans on a des
études qui suggèrent qu'il ya une
atteinte du cerveau chez 3 patients ce
pas très réjouissant les vaccins les
effets secondaires à long terme que
j'aimerais bien être au courant d'une
étude de vaccins dans la vie avant la
coved qui montre qu'il ya des effets
secondaires à long terme des vaccins non
y'a pas c'est un boost à un moment donné
il peut y avoir une réaction immunitaire
fâcheuses lors de cette injection lassé
des effets secondaires au vaccin mais à
long terme j'ai jamais eu d'effets
secondaires des vaccins inventaire
d'accord mais jusqu'à présent aucun des
vaccins passée n'était à arn messager
c'est justement le fonctionnement de ce
vaccin nouvelle génération qui rassure
les experts quand on compare un virus
avec le vaccin et qu'on comprend comment
ça marche à aucun moment on peut dire je
préfère rencontrer le virus
d'un côté comme un enfant s'infecte il
reçoit les coronavirus complet actif
avec une vingtaine de type de séquence
dahir n 10 points qui permettent au
virus de pénétrer ces cellules et de se
reproduire de l'autre camp on vaccine on
injecte comme un film en soute ce virus
un de ces arn messager qui permettra
ensuite à nos cellules de produire
brièvement une autre petite partie du
virus les spicules cette présentation du
spéculoos système immunitaire lui
apprend alors à reconnaître le virus
donc quelqu'un qui a peur de rencontrer
le vaccin puisque le virus contient
exactement la même chose comme arn
messager comme parti s'il a peur de
rencontrer de vaccins mais il va y avoir
encore plus peur de rencontrer le virus
parce qu'en rencontrant le virus il va
rencontrer ce cas dans le vaccin est
pire
après ce vaccin comme après un vaccin
plus conventionnel ou même une infection
la suite des choses est à peu près la
même rien de nouveau le système
immunitaire s'arme pour une prochaine
infection au frein dans ce cas une
protection contre les infections
symptomatique de 91% selon l'étude de
pfizer bio ntech la rn messager lui se
dégrade en quelques heures cette
technologie est scruté depuis des
décennies par des scientifiques de
multiples disciplines j'ai pas entendu
de collègues nous dire écoutez nous on
est vraiment inquiet pour dans 10 ans 15
ans 20 ans aucune alarme non plus du
côté des cancérologues le pédiatre
infectiologues jesse pape enberg
explique ça prend un stimulus nocifs
prolongé pour évoquer un cancer on parle
de tabagisme c'est pas fumer pendant une
semaine qui veut te donner le cancer des
poumons
l'exposition est tellement
restreintes dans le temps et en termes
de doses que y avait aucune possibilité
ce bateau physiologique pour penser
qu'un vaccin aurait le message et
pourrait causer un cancer depuis qu'on a
d'elle temps est encore pire avec
omicron tout le monde va l'attraper
c'est à peu près une certitude on va
tous rencontrer le virus et donc comme
on fait ce calcul bénéfice risque ou
bien on en arrive à la conclusion assez
simple vaut mieux attraper le vaccin que
le virus sahili a aucun doute là dessus
un autre élément a pesé lourd dans la
balance des comités le bien-être
psychologique et social de l'enfant et
son apprentissage
honnêtement en termes comme pédiatre on
est beaucoup plus inquiet de ses impacts
là parce que ça va avoir un impact à
long terme surtout qu'on a vu cette
année les bénéfices de la vaccination
pour la scolarisation des plus grands
les adolescents de 12 à 17 ans
si on regarde à l'automne 2009 un don
dernier où il y avait personne de
vacciner c'était dans les écoles
secondaires qui avaient les plus grand
nombre d'éclosions suivait le primaire
suivait le préscolaire les garderies est
là depuis le début de cette rente réussi
avec 80 % des adolescents qui ont reçu
les deux doses on a quelques corps qui
n'évolue pas vers des éclosions dans les
écoles secondaires
pendant ce temps les enfants étaient au
québec le groupe le plus touché à
l'automne c'est pour ces raisons que le
comité d'immunisation du québec a
tranché de manière unanime les bénéfices
du vaccin surpasse les risques ils
arrivent à la même conclusion que son
pendant fédéral que santé canada que la
food and drug administration' aux états
unis et que l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
quand je vois à quel point ces débats
sont intenses intelligent bien fait ça
me rassure complètement le dit la
probabilité que tous ces comités sur la
planète disent la même chose et que
cette même chose soit fausse elle est
allée à peu près à 0 après d'intenses
débats le comité a choisi de recommander
au gouvernement d'offrir le vaccin aux
enfants plutôt que de vacciner les
enfants une recommandation ou moins
forte que dans les groupes plus âgés
y a rien d'obligatoire dans cette
recommandation là on a on s'est bien
rassuré que le vaccin et ne serait pas
attaché au passeport vaccinale justement
parce que le bénéfice direct pour
l'enfant c'est pas la même chose que le
bénéfice direct une vaccination pour une
personne de 65 ans et plus soit on est
on est tout à fait d'accord avec ça
ce sera donc à chaque famille de faire
son évaluation comme le rappelle
l'éthicien antoine payot
ensuite la manière avec laquelle on va
décider ce qui est important pour soin
des peaux de nos propres valeurs de nos
valeurs familiales
un autre élément pourra aussi influencé
la décision le choix d'aider la
collectivité en se vaccinant pour
freiner la propagation globale du virus
est ce que dans les discussions on voit
que le bénéfice collectif soit aussi un
bénéfice pour soi même et ça fait aussi
partie du vivre ensemble qu'on décide de
se protéger soi-même pour protéger les
autres et ce ne sera pas la première
fois qu'on vaccine un groupe pour en
protéger un autre par exemple on vaccine
les enfants contre la rubéole une
maladie bénigne pour eux mais grave pour
les foetus des femmes enceintes
vaccination des enfants se déploie sur
tous les continents quand on tombe dans
les données du la vraie ville du vrai
monde le pharmaceutique n'est plus là
pour gérer les résultats c'est du vrai
de vrai il ya rien d purée
les experts universitaires l' oms les
institutions gouvernementales traquent
les ai faits plus rares impossible à
déceler lors des études cliniques
précédente aux etats unis huit millions
d'enfants de moins de 11 ans ont reçu
leur première dose on n'a découvert
aucun nouvel effet secondaire grave et
rapporter un très faible tony hawk
ardite bien inférieur à celui des
adolescents
savent à ksar et scruté mais à la loupe
c'est à dire que yens en plus des
processus de surveillance qui existent
déjà qui sont robustes parce qu'on on
détecte des effets secondaires au niveau
planétaire aussitôt qu'il ya quelque
chose de nouveau la communauté
scientifique se parle il ya un nombre
d'experts incroyable qui passe à travers
de ces données il ya une ombre de
reproduction incroyable de toutes ces
expériences donc plein de laboratoires
du monde entier ce soit la séquence du
virus la séquence de la rn message et la
façon dont les plasmas des patients sont
testés en termes de neutralisation en
termes de toxicité
c'est certain qu'il arrive presque
toujours qu'on se pose la question est
ce que cette recommandation le concept
d'un point de vue populationnelle ou au
meilleur de notre connaissance est-ce
qu'elle s'applique bien à nous est ce
que demain matin on est prêt à
l'appliquer chez nous ou pour soi même
tous les pédiatres que je connais nous
vacciner leurs enfants
on aime nos enfants je peux vous jurer
qu'on aime nos enfants on sait calculer
les risques sinon si on le fait pour nos
enfants pour nous nos nièces c'est con
parce que c'est safe comme tout le monde
y pense tous à la question est-ce que je
prends la meilleure décision pour mon
enfant les données étaient là j'ai dit
bon on niveau
c'est avec ce mec te dos c'est fini
[Musique]
je pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]